bonjour à tous j'ai si ces coûts et la
tactique aujourd'hui nous allons parler
du conseil régional alors c'est quoi le
conseil régional le conseil régional est
une organisation institutionnelle et
administrative française il y à 25
conseils régionaux en france et 1757
conseillers régionaux le nombre de
conseils régionaux va passer à 14 début
2016 sont à la récente modification du
découpage territorial votée le 17
décembre 2014 le nombre de conseillers
régionaux lui varie en fonction de la
population de la région ils sont élus
depuis 1986 au suffrage universel direct
pour sinon la réunion le conseil
régional concours 45e' lui et son siège
est à proximité du campus de
l'université de la réunion hautmont fia
à saint denis la forme du bâtiment est
particulière il s'agit d'une pyramide
renversée
c'est d'ailleurs comme cela que l'on
appelle souvent la région à la réunion
mais le nom officiel des sièges et
pierre lagourgue haut l'honneur de son
enfant président et à quoi ça sert le
conseil régional le conseil régional à
de multiples compétences le
développement économique et les aides
aux entreprises l'aménagement du
territoire la formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage et l'orientation la
construction et la gestion des lycées et
de leurs personnels l'environnement et
la transition énergétique
les équipements structurants comme
certains ports et aéroports par exemple
et depuis 2014 les fonds structurels
européens comme le feder et à la réunion
quelles sont les compétences du conseil
régional les compétences du conseil
régional 2 la réunion sont multiples il
travaille sur les affaires européennes
l'animation du territoire la coopération
régionale la culture le développement
économique l'éducation et la mobilité la
formation professionnelle
l'environnement la recherche le sport
les tic technologies de l'information et
de la communication quelles sont les
aides du conseil régional
la région apporte des aides et les
subventions pour favoriser le
développement et l'économie dans
différents secteurs d'activité comme le
tourisme les technologies de
l'information et de la communication la
pêche l'artisanat l'industrie la culture
l'environnement l'énergie le sport
l'audiovisuel si les mailles multimédia
l'ingénérie financière le transport
l'éducation et la mobilité l'émergence
de projets et caetera et concrètement
qu'elles ont été et seront les grands
chantiers financés par le conseil
régional le conseil régional à financer
en partie le trans eco express il a été
financé par la région à hauteur de soi 3
% il s'agit d'un nouveau service en
faveur des personnes à mobilité réduite
dont l'ouest depuis 2014 douves navette
aux couleurs de la région sur le
territoire de la côte ouest la nouvelle
route du littoral
les travaux ont commencé en 2013 et
seront finalisées pour 2020 et il
s'agira d'une route gratuite son péage
avec une emprise réservé pour un futur
tcsp
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est le conseil régional à bientôt
pour un nouvel épisode
je